do you know why I lose all the time I
only look for yes you got your
perspective don't you want to be happy
[Music]
do you know why everyone's petrified
when I hire someone because I'm just
like you're hired
guys I've hired thousands of people over
the last 20 years I've never looked at a
resume just D rocks very wat you know we
have a very small team where we curate a
lot of stuff that goes to Bainer and he
gets mad at me these days cuz he's a oh
gee now and he's he gets mad when I hire
these random kids and by the way I hire
them from the street like just so you
know how it's actually goes down this is
real like you can go look look at the
rock in the back is real the last kid I
hired I did it in the street kid rolls
up and like you're [ __ ] hired Andy
rocks like [ __ ] but then in my mind I
laugh because I'm like D rock that's how
you got hired dick
abundance is real there's so much
opportunity please try to go into the
yes business you're in the no business
because you grew up in a pessimistic
environment whether it was the
neighborhood you grew up in your older
sibling most likely either your father
or mother you you're in the business to
say no why not you're so scared to get
tricked by something or look bad to
others your cynicism or no Ness protects
your insecurity the reason I say yes to
everything is because I don't give a
[ __ ] what any person in this room thinks
about my shortcomings or losses so much
so I don't care about what my wife kids
or parents think about my shortcomings
and losses the reason I'm so light as a
feather is I genuinely don't value
another human beings opinion more than I
value my own about myself because I have
all the context I know what my aunt you
know what how easy it is when your
intent is good do you know how do you
know why I film everything I'm not
scared of anything I have good intent do
you know why I don't sell products or
things that nature it's because I don't
need to I make my money in different
businesses not that it has anything
wrong with that everybody can do
whatever they want if you know that your
intent is good it's easy even I think
about weird [ __ ] guys I think about like
what if I hit somebody when I was
driving what if I killed somebody
this is the [ __ ] that goes through my
head what if I'm driving and I kill
somebody because they jumped out wasn't
pay attention or worst you know this is
what I read why I really stopped texting
and driving even a little bit like what
if that happened and it's crazy the way
I play chess in my head it would
obviously change the course of my life
and devastate me but it's incredible why
there's still this little voice in my
head that still makes it not okay but
boy do I give a [ __ ] about intent it's
incredible how much I navigate
everything based on intent I will let
everything right dear Rach we talked
about the other day about like how I
manage I I don't get down on anybody
I don't scream it and if your intent is
good it's all okay if I don't think
you're capable I'll fire you and try to
help you get another job and I'm being
dead serious I do it all the time
there's nothing wrong with that but I'm
unbelievably always so past
about intent if your intent is good
you're good with me forever
period and and so there's just so much
good an opportunity right this minute
and the current mainstream media
globally is just talking about so much
bad bad cells in the short-term good
always wins in the end it's just true
you know I hate things like nice guys
finish last where it's just not true
nice guys might be losing at halftime
but they win the game
nice guys always win it's just so crazy
all this fodder in the system that isn't
true
all the faking it to you make it as a
fashion brand that's a gleep or at what
every single [ __ ] twenty
three-year-old male in the world is
doing which is fronting on Instagram
because boys want girls you know and so
like I'm just unbelievably passionate in
trying to what I realized about myself
was oh [ __ ] the reason I won and I'm
good is I've never played in the vortex
I've never played in the actual rules of
life I was an F student when every
immigrant was supposed to be an A
student because education was the way
out I launched an e-commerce wine
business in 1996 right like that wasn't
I have a [ __ ] sneaker thanks for
wearing them like I've always done
things that don't make sense
I play outside of the actual game and
that has been where all my happiness has
come from and so many things have become
obvious to me by playing outside of the
rules playing outside of the rules is
the best and that's where I want people
to understand we are pandering to so
many things that just aren't true
they're just not true and so my biggest
thing is the greatest gift ever is
actually having a life there's nothing
anybody in this room including myself
will ever do that's anywhere close to as
remarkable as actually being up human
being the math is so absurd you're
literally more likely to get hit by
light
23 times than be alive like your mom
might have just got up for another glass
of wine like do you understand how
ludicrously lucky you are you could have
been a [ __ ] tree like we are we are
just we just what is very obvious to me
is that my perspective on life is just
fundamentally different and now what I'm
passionate about is putting it out there
at scale free forever and trying to
change people's perspective on this
because watching everybody navigate
right now and do things and I watch it
all the time like you can't imagine how
upset I am about the current state of
entrepreneurship the thing that put me
on the thing that I've always been my
whole life right like literally that's
right like turn off the lights I'm
pissed that was good that was good work
fix it go back the best part is somebody
probably just leaned on it which I
always think is I always think that's
the funniest [ __ ] and they're like
[ __ ] scared like oh [ __ ] um like
entrepreneurship right now is so
misbranded it's so fun it's fun to watch
because there's nothing wrong and I love
that it got cool and listen very few
people have benefited more from it
becoming cool than me but it is not the
purity of what I love right now
everybody wants to be an entrepreneur
which is very you how hard it is to be a
successful entrepreneur like the problem
with entrepreneurship is it's different
than sports and the arts if you suck at
singing you get exposed immediately if
you suck at sports you get exposed
immediately on entrepreneurship you put
it in your Instagram profile and you get
away with it for three years and so I'm
very very much passionate right now to
change people's perspective and then
after their perspective has changed and
they actually are running a marathon
because they're gonna live for 40 50 70
a hundred more years and they have so
much more time than they think when they
stop worrying about other people's
judgment literally the majority of this
room look if you're at this conference
it is highly likely
that you're living your life based on
somebody else's opinion it's crazy it's
super real I'm telling you it's super
real you might not even realize you're
doing it it's almost like subconscious
bias like you're doing behaviors based
on the outward facade do you know me
again and just it's a great time for
this because it's happening you know any
of my fancy friends have texted me and
called me in the last three weeks about
this whole garage sale thing they feel
bad for me I'm being serious they're
like what are you doing like my one
friend was like this is just this funny
text and I laughed at it myself he's
like uh bro
eight hours ago you were with the
president of Cuba and Eric Schmidt in a
super high-level discussion and this
morning you're buying teddy bears off
people's lawns and I wrote back swag
but it's interesting for me to see
people see me from their eyes
contextual it makes me realize oh [ __ ]
they value though they value the the
market they value that the opinions of
others they feel bad for me because they
think it's hurting my brand it's a very
important thing to get around tell me
why I'm gonna transition now tactically
the reason I said all that is here's the
tactical thing that I'd like to talk
about if you are not producing 100
pieces of content for Facebook Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube podcast every single
day you were leaving the greatest
opportunity in the world on the table
100 100
that's a fuckload let me tell you why if
I said you had unlimited money and you
could go to the beachfront property all
across this world and buy it all up for
a penny on the dollar a hundred twelve
years ago would you do it the answer is
yes the number one asset for this room
regardless of what you do you sell
sneakers you're in the fitness industry
or a financial adviser you're in real
estate you sell donuts
whatever you do you're trying to run for
mayor you're trying to cure cancer the
number one thing that binds everybody in
this room is that we all need
other persons attention before we can
tell them what we want from them
attention is the singular asset it is
the singular [ __ ] asset and right now
the attention of the world sits in
mobile devices at scale and there's only
seven or eight places that we really
consume content you have to figure out
how to send your message to the world in
written audio and video content now at
first you have to pick what you're good
at
before you can afford a huge team that
does what I do which is convert all my
video into written form and audio and
video at first you have to rely on can
you do video yourself are you a great
writer
are you introverted and want to do a
podcast cuz you don't like seeing
yourself on video I don't care but you
have to start talking I want to leave
this conference and get some people here
to start posting a hundred pieces of
content a day maybe fifty two of those
are just single tweets maybe twenty six
of them are Instagram stories but I'm
serious and I'm also quite knowledgeable
that most people here haven't posted a
hundred pieces of unique quality content
this year so imagine how [ __ ] I think
you really are I mean it
I tuned 'ti is remarkable there's so
much opportunity everything that you're
seeing happen in society the people that
are getting voted in the people that are
building big companies the celebrities
that are changing in society the people
that are changing the world with
positive or negative impact
everything's playing out in one place
the internet and the internet breaks
down into like seven or ten meaningful
sites right now the information sits on
LinkedIn YouTube Facebook Twitter
Instagram it's not super complicated
what's complicated is getting good at
communicating on it it's a skill you
have to respect the context you have to
make a hundred piece of content here's
why you want to sell a home
you make one video do you think that
every woman and every man in here are
gonna see it the same way do you think a
22 year old woman who makes a hundred
thousand a year is gonna see it the same
way that a forty nine year old woman
with two kids that makes forty seven
thousand a year we have these platforms
that let us target people at a specific
level that we've never seen before at
scale
anything you want to say to the world
you should minimally say 13 times
because you have to context the audience
that's seeing it you have to say when I
do things globally when I make a video
and I say hey Mexico you need to think
about how you're doing influence or
marketing if I do that versus hey you
need to think about how you're doing
influencer marketing and I posted the
people in Mexico it disproportionate is
better not only we have to have make a
hundred pieces of content you have to
make five hundred different
segmentations and media and run it
here's the good news
everything I just said sounds hard as
[ __ ] tedious as [ __ ] right but here's
the secret everything great should be
hard
[Music]